so you had a call with the fuel industry
today to talk about what's been going on
at the pumps the fuel industry suggested
yesterday that the crisis has peaked
well this morning they are beyond
frustrated i talked to the haulage
businesses diverse businesses that are
right in the heart of this
and they are
beyond frustrated because they say
they've got a government that is
ignoring the problem and when it's not
ignoring the problem it's blaming
somebody else
and coming up with half-baked solutions
so they're very concerned that action is
taken and i think that you know we're in
this situation where um the government
has reduced the country to chaos um
through a total lack of planning this
crisis this lorry driver crisis was
predictable and was predicted and the
government hasn't got a grip and what
what what would you suggest do you think
that uh key workers should have special
access to fuel is that something you
proposed we have to prioritize key
workers i mean of course you know how on
earth did we get to this um and
the fact that we're having a discussion
about whether nurses and teachers have
to be prioritized to get the fuel they
need to get to work and there'll be many
families many businesses who are tearing
their hair out about what is going on
the other thing i would do is to issue
enough visas for long enough to get us
through this crisis on the call with the
haulage sector this morning they were
clear they need the visas they need them
now there's some suggestion that they're
not going to come on train until
november
and they need them to be for six months
not three months to make them work but
what what frustrates me is um i'm saying
this as leader of the opposition where's
the prime minister on this he's he's
absent in this he needs to take decisive
action he needs to do it today does the
british public have to take some
responsibility too
well nobody wants to inflame this and
everybody
needs to act accordingly but this idea
of somehow
turning it on the public that it's all
their fault anxious members of the
public who are thinking how do i get to
work how do i get my kids to school um
how do i you know visit somebody in
hospital and do the things that i need
to
but but this is the responsibility of
this does not lie with the public it
doesn't lie with the haulage companies
um andy mcdonnell resigned as shadow
employment minister the last kolbernite
out of your shadow cabinet you must have
been happy to see the back of him i'm
not happy to see him go i thanked him
but the point i don't want to have a
discussion about andy mcdonald i want
our party to be focused on the country
and that's what we've the change this
week has been profound for our for our
party and you know a lot of people said
to me why are you doing this care are
you going to get it over the line took a
lot of criticism but we stuck with it
because it was a tough decision that had
to be taken you can't lose four
elections and not change you said when
you became leader we're under you
leadership the party's changed is it the
show not tell moment where you're
actually trying
to change the party from corbyn's left
to starmaz center ground
it is a show moment in the sense that
i've been saying we need to change now
we've done it and we've got this over
the line that is hugely important and it
allows us now to face the country and
and importantly set out our alternatives
i want to move the party to a position
where it focuses on what matters to
working families and i can tell you
let me tell you what that is that is a
decent education for every child uh it
is secure work well-paid work near where
people live it is a health service that
works for people when they need it and
security the reason i ask you is that
you do a big play on trust but your own
record you said in november 2019 you
backed a 15 pound minimum wage now
you've binned it
you said no no let me finish you said
when you were campaigning to be leader
you'd nationalize electricity
you've just been it it's almost like you
say one thing to win to become the
labour leader and then you change when
you're in power rather like boris
johnson what made promises at the
election
cause you're moving to the center ground
because you can't win from the left not
at all what i said in november 2019 was
in relation to a particular industrial
dispute at mcdonald's where that was the
um aim of the dispute and i backed them
in that and i'd back them again today in
relation to that the minimum wage across
the whole of the economy is a completely
different issue and what we did on
saturday was to say it should be a ten
pound minimum wage that's a twelve
percent increase two thousand pounds i'm
trying to get principles of where you're
moving the party and you won't answer
the question you're moving away from the
left because you believe that you can
win an election in the center ground i'm
moving yes or no moving it from a party
that's inward to a party outward and
moving apart it looks backwards a party
looks forward a party from the left of
the party back towards the center when
you're obsessed with this position
because that's what they just understand
they just want a clear answer i disagree
i come from a working family and i can
tell you what we discussed around our
kitchen table it was education it was
work it was health and it was security
in terms of house
do you think calling tory's scum is the
way to win back labour voters who voted
conservative in 2019 or 2021 i wouldn't
use language i'm not asking about the
language i'm asking you about whether
you think that's a way to win back
people who vote to conservatives that
used to vote later andrea raynor and i
have different approaches and different
styles and different opinions different
styles or different opinions it's not
language i would have used andre and i
talked about that um of course we have
does it have huge agreements and
disagreements look
andrew and i are working together with
one central aim and that is to get the
labour party in a position to win an
election and then to win an election do
you think conservative ministers are
scummy people i wouldn't use that
language it's not language i've ever
used in relation to either conservative
ministers or anybody else